hello everyone I hope you're all having
a wonderful Sunday and if not this game
will surely improve it this is a an epic
game from the Soviet Championship played
in 1954 in Kiev in Ukraine and here we
have the no reverse gear Rashida TBI
tuition is Medina vs the iron tiger tear
and our town which Petrosyan the future
world champion and it's a this is such a
delight you know truly a feast for the
mind as there are probably no two styles
that are more opposite than the one of
Russian nourishment you know and Tigran
Petrosian so let's let's see this game
Rashid opens up the game with E 4 we
have c5 Knight to f3 d6 and d4 we have C
capture snide captures and 90 to f6
Knight to c3 and a6 by Petrosyan so he
goes for the night over at night or
variation of the Sicilian Bishop to g5
Knight B to d7 and now we have this
Queen to f3 move and Petrosyan
immediately goes for h6 now this is this
is a move that's useful in a lot of ways
and it's not a move that an attacker
like recognized Medina once the once the
face as now we have to decide do you go
Bishop b3 do capture do you go Bishop to
h4 the problem with the move like Bishop
to h4 let's say after something like
Queen to c7 you you never really have a
chance to play Queen to g3 and Queen to
g3 is a move that every attacker loves
to play because now that the Queen comes
in g3 there's always this g5 move and
you've taken away the g3 square for the
bishop to retreat so after this h6 move
of course nisman Tina doesn't want to
give up the bishop pair so Bishop to e3
we have g5 now Knight to f5 and g6
Knight to g3 and here we have b5 another
interesting move would be to play h5
here but there's a reason that Rosen
doesn't go for h5 because this allows
Bishop to c4 and after b5 and Bishop to
b3
black is perfectly fine here but you
don't want to give a Russian agent Dean
of any open lines so instead after
Knight to g3 plays Bishop b5 not
allowing this Bishop to be
developed on c4 as he knows this is
exactly what era she wants
so h4 and we have h5 stopping any
opening of the position by Rashid Bishop
back to g5 and now Bishop to e7 here
queenside castle manage Medina of Bishop
to b7 and kink the b1 wrote the c8
castling is also fine in this position
but Petrosyan wants to leave his options
open
he's gonna go rook the c8 now he will
try and create some pressure on the
Queen side maybe with a 5 B 4 also he's
planning to play Knight to c5 to create
a lot of pressure on this c4 pawn so not
castling immediately he likes to leave
his options open and we have Bishop to
d3 now and you can see that already this
isn't a kind of position that nurture
Medina would enjoy the entire position
is closed
he doesn't have any open lines so he has
to he has to play what he can Knight the
c5 now we have 9 3 2 now Russia is
preparing Bishop to g4 after he captures
the knight on f6 and we have b4 here and
here you can't move the knight if you
move the knight then this this c4 pawn
is weak as its effect 3 times so here
first Bishop captures on f6 Bishop
captures and now Knight to d5 Bishop
captures pawn captures and here we have
Queen to e7 an interesting move again
why doesn't Petros in capture on h4 if
you capture on h4 this is perfectly fine
for black but again this allows g4 and
Petrosyan doesn't want to allow Rasheed
any open lines so you know he wants to
keep the position closed and positional
so let's say Queen to f6 here after
Queen h3h captures on g6 Queen captures
on g6 and still black is fine here but
now Rashida does have some pressure the
rock is attacked on c8
no reason to go into this so after this
each character's on d5 Petrosyan plays
the very simple Queen to e7 now
threatening pawn to e4 winning a piece
this forces Rashida to play Knight to g3
and only now the Spade rose
capture on edge for Bishop captures
because now the night is preventing the
pond energy to be pushed forward we have
night back to e4 again Rashid is
preparing this g4 move he wants to open
up those lines but Bishop to g5 again
preventing g4 if you put g4 now then
h4 and now Petros and has a very strong
passed pawn here so after Bishop to g5
g3 is played or she doesn't fall out
Petros and to put that pawn any further
and we have a five here
rook D to e one Knight captures on e4
Bishop captures on e4 and now f5 Bishop
back to b3 and here Bishop to f6 of
course you don't want to push you for
here it does seem like you're pinning
something but this actually loses
because we can simply capture the pawn I
have kept so I'm sorry
as captures any foreign drug captures
you lose the Queen
so after this Bishop to d3 move Bishop
to f6 and we have Bishop to b5 check
King to f7 and this is move 26 and
Petrosyan still had hasn't canceled he
waited to see what Rashid will do and
now he finds a sanctuary for his King on
the f7 square where the King will be
very safe Queen to b3 and ink to g7
getting the King are this diagonal you
know it's it's he's gonna be much safer
here and it's not like Rashid has any
forcing move here to do we have f3 not
allowing this efore push and now h4 g4f
captures F captures and now rush back to
g5 again keeping everything closed
Bishop back to d3 and here we have h3
Bishop to a6 attacking the Trojans rook
and here you have a couple of options
you can go up to a8 you can move the
roof somewhere else but it's better to
move it to 8 as this comes with a tempo
on the bishop so rook to a8 attacking
the bishop on e6 and here comes a very
nice snitch Medina move rook captures on
h3 now what's the idea behind rook
captures an h3 this is a
this is quite crazy I mean if rook
captures Queen captures rook captures
Bishop it seems like the Trojan is
clearly winning a piece here but is he
really that's the question
so let's check it out if sorry if rook
captures on h3 then Queen captures on h3
rook captures on a6 and what is
Rasheed's idea here Rock - h1 so what
now you have to play Queen to e8 and
this is a move you have to find if you
play moves other than Queen to e8 then
white can do some serious damage
so Queen to e8 and after Queen to h7
check King to f6 now comes Rock to f1
check you have to block with the bishop
on f4 and again after Queen to h4 check
you have to play King back to g7 and now
after rook to h1 again and now now
Rashid would be threatening Queen h7
back to h4 creating a perpetual and this
is the move you will have to find Queen
to f8 and now after Queen to h7 and King
to f6 Queen to h4 now comes King to f7
and after Queen to h7 again you still
have to be very careful it's quite a
poisonous position if you play something
like King e8 then we need to be 7 wins
the rook the rook has nowhere to go
so after this King to e8 move sorry
after this Queen to h7 check you have to
block with Queen to g7 and now black has
refuted White's attack and he is
definitely up a piece and winning this
game but from this rook to captures on
h3 move you have to see 10 moves ahead
and those 10 moves have to be surgically
precise so it's not like this variation
was out of petrol since reach to
calculate but here he's playing against
her she dodged Medina and he doesn't
want to allow him this he finds another
move that that simplifies the position
which is totally in his style and he
plays Bishop to h4 now
Najma tneows Bishop is attacked on a6
his rook is attacked anyone and he has
to he has to play rook rook to h1 if he
moves the bishop you lose the rook so
nothing to do here really rook e8 1
and here rope captures on a sexist plate
now it seems like petrosyan want a piece
but it's not all that clear there is
only one move in the position that
inertia Pitino finds and that is g5 now
you're blocking the Queen's protection
of the bishop an h4 also if you capture
with the bishop then you lose the rook
on h8 so only move as quick a person g5
and now energy mattina plays Bishop to
see Queen to c4 this comes with a triple
attack on the bishop on h4 and also it
it attacks the rook on d6 so rook to a7
you have to move the rook and now comes
Rock captures rook captures and now
Petrosyan is attacking edgenuity knows
Queen and c4 and also the rock on h1
here you have to you have to capture the
rook otherwise you're gonna be done a
whole rook
so Queen captures Queen captures and the
rook captures and after the storm settle
down you can see that Petrosyan is up
one point but it's a rock ending you
know he's up one pawn there's there's
the old saying that all rock and games
are drawn even if one one player is a
pawn up but here you have another very
important thing it's the principle of
two weaknesses if you can see here black
has this very strong past G pawn and
here white White's King is so far away
white white white needs like five moves
to get his King into the game and the
other weakness is the weak d5 pawn there
is no way for white to protect this d5
pawn I mean he can protect it with a
rock h1 to rope to d1 but then there's
no stopping the Jeep on so here rock to
see someone was played this Petrosyan
would find this move like well in his
sleep
going for rook to c5 winning the d5 pawn
rook to h1 we have Jesus g5 now King to
c1 and here you see the problem Nash
Mateen off can't really bring the King
in if he brings the King in then simply
rook c5 and the the pawn is one and if
you play rook here then you block the
King from Rita from coming into the game
so those are
some unsolvable problems for white
unfortunately Rock the c5 by Petrosyan
now rook to d1 and now simply king g6
bringing the king into the game to
support the past G pawn to promotion
rocked d2 hoping to bring the King into
the game but g4 is coming Kingdom 1 and
now King at five and it was in this
position that Rashida battery snooze
Medina of resigned the game what if you
resign well you can't prevent both
threats rook has to move with check now
you have to go behind the past pawn now
black and simply win the d5 pawn and
after a couple of more moves let's say
rook g6 going after the pawn but after
rook D - yes you will win the G for pawn
but now black wins all of these pawns on
the Queen side and that's simply too
much to take so after this King f5 move
Rashid resigned the game and a great
victory for Tigran over town which the
Trojan future world champion now I do
hope you enjoyed this game as she really
tried to open those lines for the entire
game and it's interesting that Petrosyan
didn't always play the strongest move
but he played the move that that he knew
that would bother news media of the most
so not if he even didn't grab a piece
immediately whenever she'd offered it
even though he could but you know he
played a car move and he knew that that
that's the way to play against the no
reverse gear Rashid now this game was
played like I said in 1954 that's nine
years before the Trojan won his World
Chess Championship title against Mikhail
Botvinnik that match was in 1963 but you
can see even in even in his younger days
he was quite a quite a capable player
and probably one of the few that could
actually stop his mightiness attacks and
the one other thing I wanted to show you
this is the tournament table the final
standings after the tournament
you can see that petrosyan won only
fifth place in this tournament or a she
won seven place and here you have yuri
other back in first place with 14 and a
half points so that's you know for a
Soviet championship with all of
these Russian legends that's quite an
accomplishment you're the other body is
still alive today he's 95 years old and
I believe he's the oldest living a
grandmaster
so very nice mr. Yuri in second place
you have marked diamond of third place
Viktor Korchnoi here you have got
elicits in our guinea hollow eliciting I
have a book of his it's a book called
strategy and tactics in chess it's in
three parts and it took me I went
through this book some ten years ago it
took me a year and a half to finish all
three parts as you do have a lot of
positions the salt and the third book is
about finding a game plan so it's an
excellent book I really recommend it to
everyone if you have a chance do get it
as my tactics really improved and you
really get a lot of a lot of attacking
ideas and a lot of planning ideas after
finishing the game finishing the books
and here like I said petros I'm in fifth
place you have calm over a teammate in
sixth and some other very famous Russian
names like sweatin Alexey here here we
have effing Yeller floor solo under a
Lilian Paulo look at him all the way
back so we can imagine what a strong
tournament this was so yeah like I said
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank ignacio's Fernandez George Peppard
and Iran and cinnamon for a contribution
to my channel and also dr. Becca for a
contribution in Bitcoin thank you a lot
I really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon and hope this game improve
your Sunday season